okay Charles I think you're wrong in one
part of that calculation oh
we go
astrophysicist slap down
here I'll go meet you in the octagon
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition and
we're gonna do a grab bag today love me
some grab bag and of course I got my
co-host Chuck Nice Jack hey hey Neil
what's happening all right all right and
Gary Gary Riley former photographer and
who do we have to help us out with grab
bag
returning Champion the returning
Champion our go-to geek in Chief
Professor Dr Charles Lou ciao Express
um hi Chuck hi Gary let me remind people
I am a total card carrying geek but in
the same room with Charles I am a rank
amateur
modest sir it's such a pleasure to be
here with you all and have a great time
as always it's a grab bag we don't know
where these are coming from or where
they're going but there are questions
from our patreon supporters and anything
and everything goes Gary why don't we
lead off with you you got questions for
us I certainly have and uh as you've
already alluded to they're all sourced
from our patreon patrons so thank you
very much
stick with us because we might well be
asking your questions throughout the
show um first up Christopher Fowler he
says greetings to the good doctors Lord
nice and me uh interesting oh we're
going straight for sci-fi in Star Trek
the Next Generation there was at least
one episode with a game called
parisi's squares correct pronounced yes
yes thank you right yes okay on Star
trek.com it describes the sport as one
played by opposing teams of four wearing
padded uniforms and using an ion Mallet
yes what kind of sport is this and could
it be possible to actually achieve
technology technological advancements to
allow an ion Mallet just to be clear I'm
already out geeked because I didn't see
the show I don't know anything that you
just said in that question and Charles
is right all on top of it so oh there
you go Parisi squares is a fascinating
game that no one knows how to play
because it has never been shown on
screen actually so it first was
mentioned in the first season of Star
Trek the Next Generation it when the
binar episode you guys remember that one
11001001 and they were fixing the
Enterprise and so the crew had time to
take it easy and so four members of the
crew uh went to go play Parisi squares
with the team of the people who are
working down at the space station to fix
the Enterprise uh they seem to be
carrying suitcases presumably containing
the ion mallets and they were kind of
padded like lacrosse players but they
had like shorts on and stuff like that
so since then we really have no idea how
it's been played but it's been mentioned
over and over again and actually it
doesn't sound like the rules have stayed
roughly the same it started like a this
an s episode like a friendly match-up
with like maybe four guys and four other
guys would come together and they would
play each other and like maybe whack
some sort of ball back and forth with
some sort of a mallet like croquet or
something like that right but then it
got darker like there were riots
involved people could get hurt uh Riker
I think at some point got like so hurt
in parisu squares that that the doctor
warned uh a doctor Crusher at that point
right I think it was uh warned you know
be careful because next time you're
gonna break your neck and then I won't
be able to fix that so easily and then
um in Star Trek Voyager uh the doctor
the emergency medical hologram had
created a temporary holographic sort of
fake family and his fake daughter
holographic daughter played Parisi
squares and died
died and they couldn't even fix her with
all of the medical technology on Voyager
supposedly according to this uh
holographic thing I mean uh that's
pretty it's like a hologram died yeah in
the in the fictitious story of the
doctor creating why can't you just fix
the Hologram I don't get it that so
actually the episode is pretty cool you
got to watch it it's kind of cool the
way they sort of describe the difference
okay I'm sorry I have watched seven
different generations of Star Trek just
piece together this story I'm sorry it's
all on streaming the geek credentials
it's all streaming you can get to it
it's not too late okay anyway
but the reality is I think precious
squares is something like hockey
something like hockey but I really don't
know what because unfortunately it's
never been shown on screen I would like
to think that it's kind of like the game
Triad which was played on the Battle
Star Galactica the original series back
in 1978-79 that was a cool game but we
saw people playing Triad on that show we
never saw people playing Parisi squares
on Star Trek well tell me about this ion
Mallet what is it yeah yeah and what
would be what would be the uh benefit of
having an ion Mallet well you know how
mjolnir Thor's hammer is like a serious
Mallet right uh so I imagine that the
ion Mallet was like an energy version of
Milner's hammer and what was happening
is that this big fat energy ball of some
kind of zipping around the court right
and you gotta run uphill downhill round
back and forth to get it and the only
way you can get is to whack it with the
Mallet uh kind of like the bludgers in
quidditch uh the Quidditch right yeah
you got the big things whacking the ball
back and forth because you don't want to
get hit by one of those big balls coming
at you that's my guess and because
they're played on spaceships as well as
in stadiums they got to make the Mallet
small enough that you can carry them
around that's like big like hockey
sticks of lacrosse sticks so the ion
allows you to change their size and
their effect areas without having to
make a very large piece of metals right
oh interesting interesting that's my
guess
okay so you know how much mjolnir weighs
for Thor oh you figured this out once
didn't you I did but but I got it wrong
because I got no geeked really oh tell
us yeah I I calculated uh because they
set this had nothing to do with that
game or the person's question but you
did mention mjolnir of yeah
take it where it goes Neil I did
calculate it and they in in the Thor
film they said it was forged
um uh in the heart of a Dying star and I
said well we're astrophysicists we we
deal in dying Stars so I got this so you
can get it you can make a mount a a
hammer out of out of white dwarf
material but why stop there Neutron out
of a neutron star that's right so I did
this and you and I got the volume of
mjolnir because I have a replica of it
and so once you get the volume and you
get the density you get the total mess
and it has the mass equivalent of a herd
of 300 million elephants
oh that's all okay
I was actually measured
wait just hold on so that's where the
hook tried to pick up and he couldn't
okay so I put this out there proudly and
then it was like you're wrong Dr Tyson
um mjolnir actually weighs this is the
this is an interesting usage of the word
actually about a completely fictitious
object
so apparently Marvel issued a Thor
trading card in 1991 that reported the
precise weight of Thor's Hammer as 42.3
pounds
[Laughter]
now I think my answer is way better than
that one even though it's wrong that
must be a commemorative 42.3 pounds
to the universe and in the audience
I don't need to be this much of a fan
but this fan said Dr Tyson on that card
they didn't say which planet it weighed
that much on I said yes
that was good they were helping me out
wow they felt bad for me
but that's kind of cool though yeah it's
kind of cool there's some really cool
observations so that means it's all
magical it's magical it's not a literal
weight it's a he really needs the power
of of honesty and integrity yeah
worthiness worthy worthy excuse me
Worthy is the word there was actually a
period of time to show a a comic book
series called the Unworthy Thor where
for a moment there he could not pick up
the hammer because he was briefly
unworthy
I suck so bad
that's how they played a Chuck that's
exactly how they played it all right
let's keep going I love that question
here we go all right you want to go Joe
all right Dale Bloomfield right uh that
has been quite busy with the questions
but we'll start with this one if we were
able to high jump have a high jump event
on the moon
what height do you think people could
get to and also because it's stuck in
track and field obviously how big a
field would we need if we had Javelin on
the moon as well uh Chuck this part's
For You Chuck Nice chuck if you don't
read this question out then the Eagles
won't make the playoffs this year
well thank God for you Gary
there you go
there's no atmosphere but something can
go through the air on the moon if you
put in a force into it now the surface
of the Moon has a gravitational
acceleration about 1 6 that of here on
Earth so you could imagine basically
you're going to be up in the air
six times longer longer yeah so right
now the world record for a high jump is
about eight feet right so if you jump
eight feet now but that's all the time
you have in the air
multiply that by six and that's the
minimum amount of gain you would have so
48 feet 48 feet but why because it's
yeah because it's an acceleration it is
actually a quadratic term in the
distance traveled so you can make a
quick calculation you know vot plus one
half a t squared and you may wind up
with higher depending on how much push
you get off the ground with your muscles
okay Charles I think you're wrong in one
part of that calculation oh
okay we go
astrophysicist slap down
here I'll go meet you in the Octagon
okay squares okay so Charles you would
calculate the high jump by going from
this person's Center of mass and let's
say the jumper is seven feet I think
they're pretty tall but let's just get
use round numbers so there's Center Mass
is let's say halfway up so they're only
going four and a half feet above their
Center of Mass to clear the bar okay
okay so now you take that four and a
half feet multiply that by six
and then you get 24. five six seven you
get so then we'll jump 27 28 feet rather
than the 48 so I think that's how you
need to do the calculation I'm pretty
sure that may well be true yeah the
other thing here is we we've seen the
first we thought as the go-to technique
to get a world record here on Earth do
we think that that technique which is
almost a vertical takeoff
could apply to that technique going that
high on the moon that's a great question
and because would you then have to have
a running and then try and kind of
almost like fly over the bar right it
almost becomes like a pole vault right
the the human body is going at such high
altitudes because pole vault is like 20
feet ish for a world record but clearly
whether it's your 30-ish feet or my
40-ish feet it's still up at such a high
level that the human body's reaction or
position may have to be changed to be
optimally crude that's a great Point
interesting point so Charles what you're
saying is I can twist my body go
backwards Over the Bar
in the short time that I'm Airborne
correct but if I'm Airborne six times
longer I might be able to optimize for
something else yeah or just a minute now
they're forward oh
they're forward motion
is tuned so that they leave the ground
such that they're at their highest point
by still moving forward yes
right but that's pretty close to the bar
because they're like how long are they
Airborne but if you're born six times
longer you're gonna have to leave the
ground sooner yeah
so you so the bar is over like on one
side of the room you're on the other
side of the room and when you land
you're all the way over there as opposed
to inches away when you're just supposed
to inches away exactly so it's almost
more of a parabolic Arc think about
think about the floor routine in
gymnastics where they do the tumbles and
then all of a sudden uh gymnast will
just pop and produce a double somersault
and then land on their feet right what
if you took that kind of
technique towards clearing a bar for a
jump on the moon right well the reason
why seriously we're able to do that
though the floor is sprung right that's
because the floor is helping them to
replace returning energy to them to do
that you would have to do that talking
about the physics and return energy no
that's right but you see then again an
honorary degree for Chuck okay so we get
things guys
absolutely then you're balancing that
spring floor and return of energy
against the reduced gravity yeah so it's
very interesting and of course none of
us have taken yet into account the fact
that if you're actually on the moon
you're not just launching yourself up
into the air you're launching your
entire spacesuit so you've got a lot
more mass to work on unless you're
sealed indoors in a habitat or
environment so maybe three or four years
from now when we actually have a moon
base with human beings living inside
some building we'll find out exactly the
answer to this question
cool cool guys we got to take a quick
break okay this is Star Talk Cosmic
queries grab bag Edition with our geek
in Chief Charles Lou will be right back
we're back start talk Cosmic query
sports edition I got a geek in Chief
Charles Luth Charles you are professor
of astronomy and physics City University
Staten Island I get that correct that is
absolutely right all right so who's
who's next on the question line there we
got uh Jay Hunter
these are patreon exclusives that we'll
move into for those of you who support
us through patreon and by support I mean
give us money thank you thank you
Jay Hunter says uh what up Chuck Dr
Tyson Dr Lou and Gary what would playing
soccer
oh look like on our neighboring planets
what what sports would be possible to
play on Jupiter and Saturn
Wow first of all Gary what what planet
would you like to play soccer on yeah
let's ask him that this one okay okay
[Laughter]
um
we're going to change the game
completely if we take it off world
because if we go to a planet where there
is less gravity do we need a heavier
ball if we have a heavier ball can we
actually kick it
are we going to be if we use the similar
ball we can kick it forever so The
Field's going to be three miles by two
um if the air density is much lower then
you're not going to get your Magnus
effect no you're going to get all those
fancy kicks so there's a lot of things
going against it it might it it would
need to be something close to the
gravity and atmosphere that we have here
on Earth
for it to say for it to look like soccer
yes
you know what if they were on a planet
with lighter uh gravity Gary didn't you
think that maybe we could increase the
size of the field and increase the
number of players per side
that would work it's just the fact that
uh at some point you're going to have to
cover distance
as an athlete and you are having to
cover more distance so you know maybe
you could supplement that by having more
players on the field at the same time
right or you
actually have co-team
so the field is big enough where one
team takes one third of one half the I
mean one half of one half the other team
takes a quarter and then they're not
allowed to go into the other zones
perfect it's almost like two games being
played at the same time but they don't
get to intermingle okay that sounds like
a cacophony but still yeah you know what
it sounds like it sounds like whatever
is going on on whatever the
circumstances of the planet the
atmosphere the gravity and everything we
should just invent new sports tuned for
that planet absolutely it sounds like to
me now that's a good idea what do you
think of that I kept trying to take
Earth rather than Port Earth Sports
there just invent a brand new thing why
not hence Parisi squares or you know if
we could actually fly on brooms we'd
invent quidditch quidditch right okay
three-dimensional basketball if you if
you're able to float or leap or do sorts
of things so you've got Hoops in
different you know in a cube and they're
on different Edge surfaces so there's
all sorts of things you could invent and
play with me we invented basketball
football soccer tennis golf etc etc we
can invent some new ones so Charles just
remind us that about I mean Jupiter and
Saturn are gaseous so what how do you
get around Saturn our gas giant planets
which means that their atmospheres take
up a huge percentage of their Mass the
surface down at the bottom of for
example Jupiter this massive thing
it's actually liquid it's liquid
hydrogen metallic so it's solid but it's
also liquid metallic and it's kind of
weird so playing on Jupiter or Saturn
would be really really hard uh anyway
you'd all be crushed by the atmospheric
pressure long before we even got down to
the surface be it solid or liquid or
metallic or rocky or stone or whatever
there's still a lot trying to play at
the bottom of the ocean that's right
interesting exactly right Chuck so I
would play near the surface I would play
near the surface at some atmospheric
pressure that would be similar to what
we can survive but then you'd be up in
the air there would be an gravitational
pull but there wouldn't be anything to
stand on so quidditch would indeed be an
ideal thing to play there but you'd have
to have some gas masks on because it
smells a lot like methane and ammonia
out there so
sign me up we've already had it we've
already had a sporting event off world
haven't we you mean golf on the Moon yes
yeah so does that that lead us to rather
than competing against each other with
atmospherics that don't work for the
human body is it not now uh a kind of
projectile sport that we enter into like
golf it might be it might be I'll tell
you what sport I would like to play in
space just try it a little bit and see
what happens cornhole
gotcha yeah okay if you toss the thing
the wrong direction he misses by a mile
and keeps going forever right so it
becomes almost like archery with a bean
bag oh archery is even is good too yeah
except that if you miss and you hit
someone's spacesuit that's not a very
nice day yeah
how far away would you want the target
to be if it were archery on a planet or
on a moon with less dense atmosphere
less gravity what would you do would you
like I mean yeah I keep targeting on
Earth
actually you would see how good you
really are at Katniss
that's Hunger Games right there okay so
um I would say actually you don't move
it that far because archery has the
arrow moving so fast that gravity only
affects the overall flight by a few
inches or a few feet good point so what
you still want sort of your
so I wouldn't change the distance that
much but maybe the target size yeah okay
that's what's consider if you did want
to change the distance it becomes much
harder to be accurate because the tiny
angle off from the launched arrow that
that angle just gets wider and wider as
you get out there and you'll start
missing targets completely so yeah
what's the use of it's easy
but what's the use of it's impossible
that's the other side of the argument
absolutely it is it's it's it's it's
that balance which is when sports are
balanced like that it's what makes them
the great thing they are when you know
it's impossible to achieve or just too
simple to achieve then it doesn't hold
that greatness correct we see with some
of the sports and just quickly uh we
dangled one of the questions how far
would a javelin go and we were thinking
that would go six times farther on the
moon is that right I think that's right
I would agree with that statement yeah
so take the world record times it by six
and for the javelin that's about I mean
and and put an unsuspecting astronaut on
the other end wait wait wait wait wait
there's a technicality here because in
our lifetime they added an an
atmospheric drag element on the tail of
the javelin so they can keep it in the
stadium
themselves are weighted
and they can maneuver the position of
the weight within the shaft of the
javelin and they needed to bring it down
because what they found was
um I can't remember his names
um oh no I think it was Hungarian he was
basically throwing it onto the track at
the far end of the Arena now that's
great as long as not people running on
it right right so they had to they had
to redesign the javelin so as they
didn't fly as far because they were
throwing over a hundred meters right
what I'm saying isn't that isn't that an
aerodynamic drag that they put on it
yeah so what is then on the moon you're
not going to have the aerodynamic drag
you just simply need a bigger boat
that's right right but if you increase
the mass then you reduce the velocity
just to compensate thrower can make yes
you will okay to keep it in the stadium
right right okay there you go so
basically it goes from javelins to uh
small trees
we're throwing small trees today people
instead of instead of saying to an
athlete keep it in the stadium you're
saying just keep it on the planet yes
exactly exactly and to Charles's earlier
point it depending on the gravity of
where you are if you do this on a comet
or on an asteroid there are things we
throw or hit that would actually go into
orbit and would never land so you have
to you have to check your Escape
velocities for what and what the sport
is for what you're doing so there
there's no little help when that happens
you know when your ball leaves the
asteroid just like oh man well it's over
guys
standing on a comet every single
fastball that Jacob degrom throws would
go into orbit or possibly even Escape
into deep space
wow okay that's cool okay who's next all
right I'll hit it Ryan gorentz uh hi Dr
says Tyson and you I'm an avid golfer
and one of my favorite things to do is
golf at higher altitude so this is an
Earthbound this is here we're back on
Earth yeah we're back we're back all
right but this is a nice little twist a
high altitude in Colorado the ball goes
10 further and is a ton of fun to hit it
as far as the pros do at sea level I
have two questions on this one is the
ball flying further due to the lower air
pressure at higher elevations and
therefore less air resistance or is it
due to the dryness of the air and lack
of humidity that gives less resistance
second part of this question what is the
relationship between ball flight and
altitude as you go higher for instance
if I hit a driver off the top of Mount
Everest could I hit a drive thousands of
yards only due to the altitude and not
to the fact that a ball flight would be
going downhill thank you and can't wait
to hear the answer
wow great question wonderful question it
also relates to why like people in the
Colorado Rockies baseball team hit more
home runs on average right because
however I I will say if I'm not mistaken
based on what I remember from a previous
conversation yes when he asked about
humidity yeah humidity makes air less
dense yes thereby making the ball go
farther yeah so it wouldn't so what you
want is high altitude and high humidity
and high humidity so the drying at the
dryer he's talking about is is not
helping impediment but it's not helping
them yeah but but it's it's it's it's an
impediment but it's compensated for by
just the right overall lower air density
right right getting at a mile high
correct right did you agree with all
that Charles well for the most part yeah
there there are so many different
variations right because the atmosphere
is not uniform and so you hit a gusher
or you hit a particular area of high
pressure low pressure you can do that at
any altitude so generally speaking
you're correct now the question about
altitude overall is very interesting too
because like if you do hit a golf ball
from Mount Everest can it go thousands
of yards well it turns out that the
atmospheric density on a planet is
exponentially decaying right so for
example from spiritually reducing when
you say okay yeah it's going down so
from here up to say the top of Mauna Kea
which is a in Hawaii right the big
island where there's a lot of telescopes
that's about four thousand meters and
the atmosphere there is about 60 percent
of what it is here on the surface of the
Earth now if you go up another 4 000
meters that is to the top of Mount
Everest roughly then it goes down
another 60 from there so it's only about
35 36 percent of the density of sea
level so that's why people need oxygen
up on Mount Everest because the
atmosphere is about 35 percent of that
Circle happens but you don't get like
linearly going up so that you might be
able to hit the ball
a thousand yards if you're a really good
driver but I don't know if you can go
thousands of yards because the
atmosphere just doesn't quite drop that
fast well plus you can look at
uh what the air resistance is on a golf
ball and how much distance it takes off
of the takes off of your shot you just
remove that air resistance and then you
get the full sort of symmetric uh
parabolic shots so it's not going to go
up by factors right dimples on a golf
ball actually use atmosphere to allow it
to float for longer periods of time so
you may hit some sort of a turning point
right where you keep getting longer and
longer and longer but then at some point
the dimples don't do their work as well
and you actually start losing the
effectiveness and you have can't hit it
quite as far because the atmosphere is
too thin right so if we had a golf
tournament on the moon the golf balls
design would be different
and curving wouldn't matter uh you
wouldn't slice a ball you wouldn't hook
a ball the ball would just go straight
from wherever you hit it in whatever
Direction you went so uh you can't bend
it around a tree uh you can't give it
back well you could give it backspin I
guess yeah on contact with the ground
yeah on contact with the ground you
could give it spin that's about it you'd
end up playing like a crazy golf Luna
Crazy Golf you'd have to hit it off a
rock or a surface okay I'll use a crater
oh wow now see that's a three cushion
pool shot that's what that would be you
know what that makes sense though
because it's only going to go straight
so you if you're shooting it at a Target
then what you could do then is figure
out the trajectory from the Target in
order to get where you want to go in the
course that's interesting wow yeah
Billiards golf so now billiard golf
that's named it here it's gileads
thank you
and so so we are people who have time on
our hands and then we go and invent
stuff like gileads
guys you gotta take another quick break
when we come back more crazy Sports
Cosmic geeky questions from our patreon
fan base on Star talk sports edition
Cosmic grab bag
we're back StarTalk sports edition
Cosmic queries grab bag with my friend
and colleague geek in Chief Charles Lee
and of course Gary and Chuck we got
there uh Charles how do we find you
what's your social media footprint these
days uh I am at Chuck Liu
c-h-u-c-k-l-i-u uh my channel is the
universe that's like a podcast and we're
doing good Universe I love that I see
what you did there yeah I know I I
thought it was a little bit cheesy but
everyone around me said no it's the
obvious I love it yeah cheesy because
the moon is made of cheese or what no
something like that yes okay now I'm
hungry okay so where do we find your
podcast well uh it's on YouTube at the
moment and and it's going to go to
different places all around eventually
but uh it's a lot of fun we talked to
younger scientists mostly where they're
at The Cutting Edge and again they find
out about them not just about their
science but them as people it's
wonderful you're beautiful again we keep
the the wheel of Education turning
absolutely from those coming up to those
the wheel of Education
you know where we'll be tomorrow though
chuck ah ah maybe Journey didn't but I
know what's in these wonderful young
scientists our future is secure with
these guys
all right who's next up with a question
it wouldn't be the same without your
letter sorry
[Music]
she's like 30 years old by now
this child's been asking questions I
think she was prenup okay so Violetta
roll uh is now 14 yeah
goes up goes under the title of
astrophysicid yes that's awesome
yes I love it wonderful all right
um will we ever reach a point in the
near future of sports when it will not
be physically possible for any more
World Records to be broken if so which
sports do you predict might get to this
point first and how far might we be from
this happening also would we even know I
mean the human body can only be pushed
so far question mark and I need the
science on this thank you you're welcome
and she's a big fan of the show as I
think I've had a show on this one time
about Prosthetics
aiding Sports and right if you if you
reach the limits of the human body would
people still come out to see the sport
if no one is capable of beating a world
record and then we said well you just
add add extra stuff because you do stuff
and then the for me the best answer to
that was in the limit then you're just
seeing robots compete and that's not the
same thing as seeing humans if the
wooden gets all the joints replaced by
Rob by robotic uh assistance so so
Charles what do you what do you think of
that question yeah I agree with that
statement it all depends on the rules of
each game right and rules of each sport
support for example if you're playing a
sport today you're allowed to wear
certain kinds of equipment you're
allowed to use certain kinds of tools
but you are not allowed to use certain
other kinds you know if you have a bat
for example you're swing at baseball
with you can use a wooden bat but you
can't use an aluminum bat right you can
have some pine tar on it but only a
certain amount of it depending on the
rules of the game
if the rules keep changing then World
Records will be able to be set without
limit provided they're changing in the
favor of performance yes that's right
like we were just saying earlier as
javelins get heavier there's only so far
you can throw them right so it really
depends on that so as far as humans are
concerned I I feel like weight lifting
is one of the most important ways that
we can measure the limits of humanity
right what are weight liver weight
lifters allowed to do what are they
allowed to use what techniques you know
the chalk the the grip the
um the gloves the
the body has a limit and then people
will push the body by adding different
kinds of training regimens perhaps if
they wish not to follow the rules they
might add certain chemicals but then
those chemicals are banned or not banned
so it really depends on how much and
what you're allowed to do that will
determine the limits but I'm pretty sure
that at some point weight lifting is
going to be limited unless you allow
robots is weight lifting they're going
to be the first one that we're going to
see this in my opinion that right off
the top of my head I think weightlifting
will be the limit yes now when you think
about it speed our physiology there is a
speed limit for us as human beings so
it's the same as in you know you're
looking at strength it's like our
muscles can only do so much and then of
course if you were able to exceed it
then there is like immediate
ramifications for doing so uh in the
body so that's another you know so you
know I'm looking at something like a
microchip that might be able to perhaps
increase like either the response times
between your Twitch but then allow you
to exceed that and not actually suffer
suffer the damage right like those type
of things can also you know make us go
past our speed limit but again so the
other thing is the other thing Charles
we had Usain Bolt come along and Destroy
100 meters world right now
that caught Everybody by surprise what's
to say someone with a very different
body shape to the classic Sprinter shape
comes along and destroys Usain Bolt's
records though Gary it's only by a few
tenths of a sec that's destruction just
to be clear people that's I think I
first saw I first noticed this in
swimming where they have touch pads that
records your arrival time at the end of
the race it might be
that the future of World Records is in
the next decimal place
so that we Peg ourselves at some number
of minutes or seconds and then tenths of
a seconds then you go to 100th then
maybe thousands and then tenths of
thousands and the whole contest might be
contested in that added decimal place
that we need in order to see what the
world record would be when my father ran
track it was four people at the finish
line with a manual stopwatch and they
would click it when they saw the sorry
it's three people for each uh Lane and
they would throw out the high and the
low and they'd use the middle score and
they're reading tenths of a second
so that you would know Hussein bolt
would win but you wouldn't be able to re
measure how much he won so it's like you
said right yeah so the other the other
thing here is you swimming and use the
100 meter sprint it's not the fact that
you run the time
then you now change a metric of saying I
did it with less strides I did it with
less Strokes
um if it's a high jump I took less steps
to get to my jump and then clear the bar
that means I would so you if if we're
getting a a a stale part of world record
and it's not being broken do we look at
other parts of the event to look to see
as that as categories of judgment and
then I broke the world record with only
so many strides in the hundred meters
are we looking at maneuvering in that
way sure you know I think what's even
more interesting than what you just said
Gary is the fact that when you have
people who have a different physiology
enter a sport more people like that
entered the sport yes the same bolt is
this lanky you know uh long-legged he's
not just lanky he's long-legged and he
doesn't even look like he's trying but
you know yeah but if you think about the
history of that sport not a lot of guys
look like Tim a lot of sprinters were
actually short
am I right in this moment I'm looking at
a runner of records of the last 12 world
records for the 100 meters and and just
to be clear we say bolts shattered the
record he beat it by one tenth of a
second that's a lot that's a lot it's a
lot compared to other increments on the
world record yeah but in the big picture
it's still a tenth of a second yeah so
what I'm saying though is imagine how
many lanky Jamaican kids right now
are running uh Sprints because of Usain
Bolt imagine how many gangly kids are
swimming because of Phelps totally
correct I think you I mean when you look
at basketball think about the origins of
basketball
I mean let's be honest you look at those
old films it's a bunch of short white
guys hanging around and then going for a
cigarette afterwards yeah
I mean you know and you look at the
sport today I mean you know a guy who's
six two is considered small I agree with
you Chuck they're all manner of body
types out there not all of which were
imagined to excel in sports my father is
among them I'll retell that story right
now where he was in his high school gym
class and they're changing units and
they say we're now going to go to track
and field unit they pointed my father to
my father online and said uh Cyril Tyson
right there everyone look at him he does
not have the kind of body that would
make a good track and field athlete
right and he said at age 15 no one is
going to tell me what I can't do with my
life and he took up track and field from
then on and he became world class had
the fifth fastest time in the world uh
for his event uh which was the the
it's not run anymore but it's the uh 600
yard run yeah and so
uh but anyhow just body types and things
maybe one body type is good for it maybe
others don't know they could be good for
it because you have other people other
idiots telling you no
so yeah I agree yeah I agree all around
I think we answered that question to
reveal
Etta sorry sorry violetto yeah we ran
away with that one wow okay yeah I feel
that Testament great questions here we
go go one I got one here and we're going
to throw it into the near future okay
okay Alejandro
for Monterey in Mexico with the FIFA
football World Cup coming up in Qatar in
November and December of 2020. right
yeah how do we think this will affect
the abilities of the player now
I mean high temperature low humidity
what what are we talking about
um with Qatar we're we're blessed
because
um normally the World Cup is a summer
event which would be brutal just to
watch the thing take place let alone
play in it so didn't they move it just
for that yes they moved it to November
December so the thing is in in November
checking this out they have about an
average temperature of 85 degrees
Fahrenheit and a humidity level of
average 66 percent
um the heat index you're gonna like this
91.4 Fahrenheit but don't forget all of
these heat indexes are measured in the
shade with a light breeze so if you're
stuck in the direct sunlight right and
there's no wind you're gonna cook
in mid-summer in July in in Qatar it's
over 100 it's 105 degrees average high
temperature and in the month they're
going to be playing what is the average
high uh so it's it's across November and
December so the thing is if you if
you're in direct sunlight and you
actually happen to be exercising which
would be a surprise for a footballer in
the world cup you can add another 15
degrees Fahrenheit to the heat index so
the heat index is going to be about 106
for an athlete in the world cup now if
you drag it into December the
temperatures go down to about 75 degrees
Fahrenheit however
the humidity levels go up to 71 average
so you've got that little you lose a
little bit to that yeah okay yeah so
it's either way you you slice it it's
going to be uncomfortable
um you know these these heat indexes are
based on people who are in the shade
like I said with a nice breeze these are
footballers that are out in the stadium
the surface temperature on the field
will be close to 100 degrees because it
just sits and bakes there's not much
Breeze to cool the surface now you're in
Doha which is quite a populated urban
city so there's not much chance of a lot
of Breeze in there so it's going to be a
very very challenging
environment and I think the teams the
organizers FIFA are going to have to
look at hydration breaks during the
either half you're going to have to
you're going to have to look at how loud
take a break in soccer there's no breaks
in soccer there never used to be you
were lucky you got half time and so
um they're going to take hydration
breaks they're gonna have to look at
development of a larger Squad so they'll
increase the number of substitutions
that take place and is it's so the
stadium is open air yeah generally I
mean unless unless they've built some
with roofs but let's hope to God they
haven't because then you know the amount
of energy it takes to you know cool a
structure like that yeah it's ridiculous
and part of the reason why it's you know
untenable to play there in the first
place is due to you know the warming
planet and like let's not make things
worse by figuring out how we can cool
things off to play you know here's a
real uh uh uh suggestion
don't play sports in the freaking desert
how about that see the thing is all
those numbers I've just relayed are
averages now we've we've had a bit of a
sizzling summer in 2022 and so is the
rest of the world
um if there is some kind of heat wave
you can bump those numbers right up so
yeah so it's just let's be mindful of
this is a challenging environment and
I'm sure what we'll do is we'll find
medical teams from each countries that
are participating will have spotters
looking at their players do you have
some they'll all have some sort of GPS
biometric data bio data coming for
hydration and everything yeah absolutely
as dramatic as soccer players are
oh God help us oh
my meat my knee I need a drink yeah I do
believe I have the vapors
you have just you have just made the
world cup so bloody interesting
[Laughter]
all right we got guys we got to end it
there oh this has been this has been fun
Charles it's always great to get you
back in the house it is great to be here
thank you so much for having me and good
to learn of your podcast tell me that
the clever name again loon the universe
the luniverse LI universe
as in Charles Universe yeah she would
see what you did there well again I
didn't do it people around me did but
I'll I'll accept it it's all good it was
a good choice thank you Chuck always
good to have you man always a pleasure
Gary love you man love you tooth this
has been star talk sports edition Cosmic
prairies grab bag Neil deGrasse Tyson
here wishing you
looking up
[Music]